oh hey I'm sorry just laying down some  dope tracks here and didn't see you  there but since you've already  interrupted my sick flow I might as well  tell you about my new feature film the  Lego Batman movie written directed sound  mix choreographed and painstakingly beat  boxed by me because I'm Batman in my  spare time I also cut together this  trailer filled with some but certainly  not all of my best hero moments and  zingers so enjoy it  Batman out women wait Batman back and  forgot to drop the mic  hey pewter I'm home I'm home I'm home  welcome home sir  initializing Batcave music so did  anything exciting happen today I saved  the city again  live is off the chain  anyway I should probably have some grub  Alfred left your Lobster Thermidor in  the fridge oh that's my favorite  I can't wait not 20 minutes stupid  I deserve this today today I deserve it